six cent trente mille personnes
contaminées et près de treize mille
morts depuis le début de la pandémie
les philippines sont contraints de
déployer les grands moyens pour tenter
d'endiguer le phénomène dans sa lutte
contre le virus
l'archipel a homologué ce vendredi le
spoutnik v une nouvelle dont s'est
félicité le directeur du fonds souverain
russe kirill dmitriev les philippines
ont été parmi les premiers pays à
s'intéresser aux vaccins spoutnik après
son homologation en russie foot nick v a
obtenu une autorisation après un examen
approfondi des données scientifiques
il deviendra l'un des outils clés pour
prévenir la propagation du coronavirus
dans le pays
au total 54 pays ont autorisé
l'utilisation du sérum russe sur leur
territoire réputé peu cher et facile à
conserver spoutnik v est
particulièrement convoité par les pays
d'amérique latine l'argentine le mexique
ou encore le honduras l'ont notamment
adopté un succès qui ne se dément pas
également en afrique au moyen-orient et
dans les caraïbes
accueillis au tout début avec un certain
scepticisme à l'étranger la cote de
popularité de spoutnik v a grimpé en
particulier depuis le mois dernier après
la publication d'une étude par la
célèbre revue scientifique the lancet tu
cette dernière faisant état d'une
efficacité de 91,6 % soit le troisième
vaccin le plus efficace derrière pfizer
biotech et modern à face à la demande
importante la russie a également signé
des accords de production de son sérum
en dehors de ses frontières
depuis ce vendredi le groupe
pharmaceutique indien astrid est entré
dans la danse street va produire à
partir du troisième trimestre 2000 21 un
minimum de 200 millions de doses de
spoutnik v suffisant pour vacciner 100
millions de personnes les volumes
importants de vaccin produit
conjointement avec streets contribueront
à élargir l'accès aux vaccins à
l'échelle mondiale outre l'inde le fonds
souverains russes a également annoncé
des accords de production sur le vieux
continent notamment
france alors que l'examen du spoutnik v
par l' agence européenne des médicaments
en vue de son homologation se poursuit